hello everyone and welcome to another
remarkable game from round two of this
year's uh Norway chess this is the
classical game alireza versus
uh you guys will uh enjoy this one it
will make your head spin but you will
enjoy it so let's dive straight into it
there is quite a lot to cover uh and
then we are going to discuss the
standings the live ratings and
everything that well should be discussed
after a classical game is shown so Pawn
to D4 we have Pawn to D5 and pawn to C4
and here mamidaro replies to the Queen's
Gambit with a d captures and C4 he goes
for the Queen's Gambit accepted and
although Knight to F3 is the most
popular move here alireza goes for E for
this considered to be the sharpest with
Pawn to E5 and Knight to F3 putting
pressure on the pawns here and the E
captures on D4 can be played of course
it is the the top move but Bishop the B4
check instead the McDonald defense with
Knight to C3 Knight to F6 and now Knight
captures on E5 and of course now white
gets the full Center black gets the
defended Pawn on C4 and it's uh it's
definitely a trade-off we've seen many
games that uh read this exact same
position we often say that the Knight
has very good chances of reaching that
D3 square and uh once the night lands on
D3 could be very dangerous and I also uh
thought about uh maybe switching from
all sorts of different defenses to the
Queen's gambling maybe to going for a
queen's game it accepted as I really
like the positions that happen for black
here I just uh haven't got a round to it
but if I find some sort of um
a nice playable uh line that that you
know you guys can enjoy in Blitz I might
even make a nice tutorial uh on it
basically making a tutorial is what will
uh make um make me a learn its own you
know hope I make that soon so okay Pawn
to F3 we have castles and Ponte A3 now
challenges the bishop and now Bishop
back to A5 this is um
uh now uh the the B4 square has been
taken from the Black Knight so you will
have to figure out a different way on
how to get your knight to D3 as
basically you can get it there via the
B4 or the C5 Square we have pawned the
A4 now B4 Square again uh gets vacated
and now there is a game where Pawn to C5
was played the para maxulum I faced this
move uh from uh Jordan Palm Forest in
this year's Tata still tournament and uh
Jordan lost that game but not because of
the C5 move I was uh you know a very uh
sharp game instead we have Pawn to A6
here by mamidarov and it is now as of
move nine that we have a completely new
game so Ali is a continuous development
Bishop D2 and now Knight F the D7 if you
guys are wondering why not just develop
the Knight where you can the C6 square
is covered by this Knight and the D7
square is also covered by this Knight
what I mean by this is if you play
Knight b37 then Knight the C6 is very
annoying okay we're not gonna lose the
version because you can always give it
up but then you lose the bishop pair and
it's not that way the queen comes to E8
you can even capture here as The Rook is
undefended so basically you would uh you
know in in the civilize the game you you
resign this yeah so instead Knight after
D7 yes you have to play with the same
piece twice in the opening but what
you're gonna do now the C6 square is
nicely covered by this Knight and uh
Bishop D3 just continuing development
and while you could trade here it
doesn't really give you all that much
for example you trade Queens it's a
white who's uh enjoying the the a lovely
development which repair The Rook
controls the D file uh the Knight is a
very nicely placed can jump to D5 after
you Castle also the pawns are doing a
fine job covering the center so nothing
to be looking forward to so instead just
spawn to C6 by shock uh and Knight
captures on D7 Knight captures and now
we have castles Bishop to B7
at some point of course you are hoping
to play C5 to open up the slide Square
bishop and queen to E1 preparing to
infiltrate the black king side with the
White Queen Ponta F5 and now you capture
now you could also decide maybe you
wanna Advance the pawn but then just
spawn to F4 is very annoying and also
the Knight will come to D5 so it would
only be helping black so instead he
captures an F5 Rook captures and now
Bishop to D1 preparing to win some uh
Tempe here uh with uh with the Bishops
attacking The Rook Rook back to F7 and
now Queen to G3 getting the queen into
the attack and The Rook will be very
helpful here you don't have to worry
about moves like Bishop to H6 so Knight
to F6 with Bishop to C2 and Knight the
D5 now putting pressure on White's
pieces here and while you could consider
a move like Knight captures on D5 and
you most certainly should uh a bishop to
G5 was played here and this is maybe a
sub-optimal idea uh you know maybe not
capture Sandy was a little bit better
because here if mamajaro wants to he can
actually play Knight captures in C3 even
though his Queen is hanging there's the
thread of night's day to check picking
up the White Queen so you'd have to play
B captures and now you play Queen to B6
so uh also one of the possibilities but
at least you eliminate one extra
attacker mommy are win for Queen to B6
right away and now alireza of course
takes advantage of this he plays Queen
to H4 we have Pawn to H6 you have to
cover the H7 Square I know you guys
forgot about our good friend the bishop
and C2 and now Pawn to H6 with Bishop
back to D2 and now Knight to B4 also B4
is an option but B4 is always an option
I'm sure you guys are already aware of
this and now for example Knight captures
spawn captures uh you get this very nice
expansion but it's very hard to free up
your your light Square Bishop here the
the slight Square Bishop is uh well for
the moment non-existent uh so instead
Knight to B4 uh we have Bishop to G6 now
attacking the rook and just Rook the F's
6 attacking the bishop Bishop back all
the way to B1 nicely controlling the
Knight on B4 and now Knights to D3 and
this is what I uh meant at the beginning
of the game somehow this Knight always
finds his way all the way to D3 as the
uh C4 Pawn nicely defends it and while
you could capture it and it even might
look like something you might be able to
win fairly soon there's just never a
good way to actually go after at this
point and it's kind of easy to defend it
so instead after this Knight the D3 move
with Bishop to E3 uh Bishop captures on
C3 with B captures and Rook to E8 now
now The Rook comes into the game with
Tempo and alireza brings it back Bishop
to F2 here you should trade Bishop
captures at night because now uh the the
bishop on F2 will be much safer however
after Rook d8 with Bishop to F2 and now
the Knight comes the F4 this is
something that maybe you should not have
allowed Knight to F4 with King to H1
sidestepping all of the nasty checks and
now comes spawn to C5 now the light
Square Bishop almost comes alive but
it's not um the the the way to play this
position the best way to play this is
Pawn to G5 but like alireza was a very
long time in the previous game here both
alireza and Shah are very very low on
time and they are well for for the last
10 moves they will be basically playing
on seconds uh this is the line you had
to play Ponte G5 Queen G3 and now
Knights the E2 you attack the queen and
once the queen moves and look at this
beautiful move Queen to E5 now how do
you deal with this do you capture the
queen if you capture the queen then you
also attack the black queen and the Rook
on F6 and now there's just no good way
to handle this C5 for example captures
captures and you will play Bishop
captures and C5 you have the bishop pair
and The Rook pair uh you know to counter
that that black queen and the white will
be perfectly fine here so that's one way
to do it the problem is of course uh
black will not go for this black will
just play Queen to d8 and now you have
to move the queen Queen to see five
Knight captures on C3 and the game
continues with uh with uh okay Black's
position being a bit preferable so
instead after King stage one Pawn the C5
was played now opening of the light
Square Bishop but now alireza plays a
capture Sun b5a capture Sun B5 and now
Queen to G3
uh aligning the queen nicely with the
King here uh and now uh how can mamiaro
continue this well he played Knight
captures on G2 which we are of course
going to enjoy uh the movie the movie
kind of should have played his Knight to
e to attack the queen and once the queen
moves and you should be moving it to G4
to add more defense to the D4 Pawn now
you just trade and now how do you
continue here see captures and Bishop to
D5 you uh close off the position you
prevent the D4 Pawn from being pushed
further and now you will enjoy those
past B and C pawn and you will start
pushing them to Victory so this was the
way to go however Mama played Knight
captures and G2 this is a move you would
expect from from Shakira now comes the
captures on C5 and this is the only move
that doesn't lose the game for alireza
and it's a movie you absolutely have to
play D captures and C5 now comes with
Tempo Queen to C6 putting even more
Firepower on this diagonal and now
Bishop to D4 now attacking The Rook of
course The Rook cannot move you will get
checkmated on G7 so Knight to E3 and
what do you make of this position can
you even see I mean what's happening
here uh well there are there are
basically two moves that you you
consider here moving The Rook Rook to F2
but it's kind of the second move you
consider the first move is just you know
let's let's start capturing everything
and see what happens and that's exactly
what we're going to do let's capture
everything and see what happens if
Bishop captures an F6 Queen captures an
F6 and now uh what do you play here if
you move the Rook for example Rook to F2
then Queen captures and C3 wins for yeah
The Rook is hanging and also Queen to C1
check uh those are two terrible threads
that you cannot Parry uh so instead
Queen to G6 should be played now
offering a queen trade but basically
going for that Rook uh that's undefended
on E8 and now I have to Rook to E6 Queen
captures on F6 Rook captures on F6 and
The Rook to E1 uh I mean it's a big mess
of a position but this is what you have
to do Bishop captures an F3 checking to
G1 the Knight Will move and you will
play something like Rook day 7 okay
white is a bit more active and it does
have the
uh the uh you know privilege of being up
the exchange black is up upon so you
know white is the one who will be
pushing for a win here uh so Bishop
captures on F6 is definitely nice uh
Rook to F2 is what alireza chose you
know keeping the tension uh like a true
gentlemen would and he says all right
try to figure out a way out of this one
shock so he plays Knights the D1 attacks
The Rook Rook to G2 now still you don't
have to worry about capturing an F3
because uh the G7 Pawn is hanging now
it's the thread of Checkmate and pawn to
G5 with Bishop to e for now attacking
the queen and now you have to part with
something a white will definitely be
winning material here you either have to
give up The Rook or or something because
the Knight and D1 is hanging as well so
Rook captures an E4 it's kind of your
only move Bishop captures an F6 now and
now Rook to E3 here uh probably a queen
captures on F6 is the safest way to go
let's say root captures on D1 Rook the
E8 and now Rook the F2 just defending
the pawn on F three Queen captures on C3
and again black will try to push those
pawns white is up material white will
try to make use of that so you know it
would be another trade-off but
definitely the best course of action for
shock uh in the game Rook the E3 was
played but now comes Rook captures on D1
Rook captures on F3 looks incredibly
scary how do you deal with this well
there is Queen to B8 with check King to
F7 and now feel free to pause the video
and try to find a win for alireza while
I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well seemingly unsupportable move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Bishop to E7 this is the
move that wins alireza did not play it
but it wasn't needed as they were both
solo on time that uh the the you know
the at the art of Defense just wasn't on
the level you would expect out of a
former 2800 player but just for fun I
will show you what happens here now what
happens after Bishop to E7 obviously
we're threatening Queen to f8 to check
so can you capture the bishop well if
you capture is just going to be a very
long King hunt now uh we have Queen the
d8 with Czech King the F7 Rook to D7
with check King to G6 and queen to E8
with check forcing the king down the
board Queen to F7 check King to E4 and
now Queen to H7 check King to E3 Rook
the E7 check King to F4 and now Queen to
F7 check and you don't have um any
choice here you have to block with the
queen and then Queen captures and F6
will be checked Checkmate so after
Bishop D7 black really shouldn't touch
that better what you should play is King
to G7 and now it takes really a lot to
win this queen to E5 with check King to
H7 and now this brilliant King to G1
move probably one of the reasons why
Bishop D7 wasn't spotted as it just
seems impossible doing anything with the
queen and Bishop battery going down this
diagonal so King the G1 the only winning
move here and the black is now uh
without uh without a viable plan there's
really nothing you can do you're down
too much material and you will get
checkmated let's say you play B4 uh Rook
to d8 and now how do you stop Rook to h8
well of course you could play Rook to f8
now threatening Checkmate but it's not a
problem we'll just bring the Rook back
defend against Checkmate and black will
very quickly run out of moves let's say
Rook to F7 Bishop to D6 nicely defended
there Pawn to B3 and even Pawn to H4 and
now black is really out of moves there
there is absolutely nothing you can play
here and the position is just winning
for white so that's what you play but
all it is a played Bishop to D4 it's the
second best move recommended by the
engine and it is enough to to win
especially since Miami is done uh
seconds on the clock and he needs two
more moves to reach time control so Rook
the F4 was played with Rook to F2 you
kind of still
uh fight after Rook to F2 uh look at
this now how do you how do you defend uh
because uh Queen captures on G2 will be
Checkmate you can't really move the Rook
there's a triple attack here uh you win
by playing Queen captures on B7 so even
this is in the position Queen captures
and now you just pick up the Rook you
have two Rooks and the bishop for the
queen uh instead a rook the F4 was
played and now comes Rook to D2 just
defending you know as those Rooks are on
the second rank you know you never have
to worry about Rook captures here so
Queen to F3 and here uh Pawn to H3 this
is a white uh White's 40th move and uh
there's really nothing to be done here
with Bishop to G1 you kind of uh win uh
even uh more even easier uh the problem
is two seconds on the clock and uh
alvareza didn't really want to waste his
20 seconds on the clock allowing mommy
after to find the best move 40. so he
played one to H3 uh played Queen
captures on H3 and he was also in this
position unmoved 40 upon reaching time
control that Shakira Mahmoud resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here he made this move with two
seconds on the clock and even though you
know it looks uh like you might have
something here because the bishop the
queen The Rook uh there's nothing there
after King to G1 there is no
continuation yeah your only move if you
don't want to get checkmated as black is
to play Bishop captures on G2 but now
the King Khan starts Queen to C7 with
Chair King to G6 Queen to G7 with
tracking to H5 and now you simply
capture Rook captures and G2 and there
is nothing here if Queen to F5 hoping
for some Perpetual action uh just Bishop
to F2 and if Queen to B1 check this is
the last check that black can give King
to H2 and now there is nothing you're
just down a piece and that's pretty much
it
upon reaching time control he just
resigned the game uh so I really really
a wild one uh could have gone either way
uh you know pretty crazy stuff here both
of them seem to be I mean okay there's a
second game in a row that he really goes
down in time travel in classical time
format now two two players being in time
travel in classical uh not something you
see very often and you see uh just how
exciting the games uh become if you
don't allow increment for move one and I
I actually prefer this you know okay you
get increment if you if you have some
sort of really complicated end game and
you need the increments to create your
Masterpiece okay we'll give you
increment uh after move 40 or maybe even
after move 60 you know at move 40 maybe
we give you additional time and then
only increment at move 60 but you know
don't don't give increment starting for
move one uh that's just silly and we
never get to see any action that's why
in in round two out of the five games
that were that were played in classical
four of them ended with a decisive
result in class skull so absolutely
incredible the other one being a
Nakamura versus gukish Nakamura has
defeated him and now for some fun after
the game here is what happened in round
two so he covered defeated gookish in
classical uh Magnus Carlsen defeated
Wesley so in Armageddon we've seen that
game uh um uh Fabiano caruana defeated
anishigiri also in Armageddon yeah sorry
three games ended by winning classical
another big defeated classical and
Algeria defeated Shakir mamidarov In
classical so that's that here we have
the standings after the second round uh
the leader is Fabiano caruana with four
and a half out of six followed by Hikaru
and norderbeck with four out of six then
with three out of six we have gukesh and
alireza two and a half out of six uh
anigiri in Wesley so with one and a half
out of six Magnus Carlton and chocolate
mamidarov and Aryan tari with one out of
six Magnus Carlsen keeping his
countrymen company in the lower lower
part of the of the of the table uh so
you know what are you gonna do and here
also you guys are probably interested in
this what uh changes in the ratings well
the big winners are okay uh Alvarez is
still uh world number two but Fabiano
Corona up 15 points in classical almost
uh 2780 going uh uh closer and closer to
that 2800 rating also Hikaru Nakamura
plus four uh anishan plus two Wesleyan
plus six uh Rapport on plus six but he's
playing a different tournament uh
kariakin also on on plus the three and
maximum also on plus four uh young plus
10 and go cash and abusator of in this
tournament uh and plus five uh minus
nine and the momentar of minus three so
that's what what's happening in the top
20 uh just in case you guys were
wondering uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it a lot of big
clashes happening in round three for
example Magnus versus Hikaru that's
always a treat uh regardless of what
time format it is if it's if the bullet
Blitz classical rapid we're going to
enjoy it and of course a lot of other
interesting clashes happening today so
stay tuned for that uh yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it sorry for
a bit of a longer video but you've I
mean you've seen the lines here there
were absolutely disgusting and beautiful
uh I would like to thank bunchak Pang
Refuge rafta's YouTube mihal sakaria
stop at the spotted and Brandon fukuda
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful tournament
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day